[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
ça fait un peu thérapie de groupe
j'ai une question à vous poser est ce
que vous pouvez s'il vous plaît me me
dire quel était le prénom et le nom du
speaker juste avant moi
il y en a ça les pique un peu dans lego
le nom de famille aux siens oui c'est
pas mal pour 10% d'entre vous ça pique
aussi légaux de marcelino ndour retenez
ce prénom c'était fabuleux la question
qu'on se pose c'est est ce qu'on est
condamné à ne pas retenir à chaque fois
un nom et un prénom and broad carte
bleue un numéro de téléphone une adresse
bitcoin
ya stéphane thomass qui se posent la
question actuellement c'est un
programmeur allemand qui habite à san
francisco en 2011 il ya un de ses
clients il l'a payé en pid cogne 7000
bitcoin c'était sept mille fois pas
grand chose ça valait que dalle à
l'époque aujourd'hui en 2022 7000
bitcoin ça vaut à peu près 3 millions
d'euros voilà et stéphane thomass ne se
souvient plus du mot de passe est
vraiment il s'en souvient plus et 35
caractère c'est un peu compliqué mais
c'est jouable quand même il s'en
souvient plus il a fait huit tentatives
sur les 10 autorisé pour récupérer ses
bitcoin est dans deux tentatives s'est
bloquée pour toujours
dommage ça c'est un dommage qu'ils
piquent un c'est un dommage à 3 millions
d'euros quand même est-ce qu'on est
condamné à ne pas se souvenir est-ce
qu'on est condamné à ne pas avoir de
mémoire notre cerveau il comporte 68 à
100 milliards de neurones pour faire
très simple on va dire que chaque
neurone contient une information et ses
neurones ils communiquent avec les
autres neurones ils ont des connections
ça s'appelle des synapses en moyenne y à
peu près cent mille synapses par
neurones ça veut dire que dans votre
cerveau le nombre de connexions entre
les neurones équivalent au nombre de
secondes qu'on peut trouver dans 31
millions d'années
l'outil est efficace celle usage qui est
très mauvais au final parce qu'au final
le mot de passe le plus utilisé sur un
site internet c'est le bouton j'ai
oublié mon mot de passe c'est bien un
signe en réalité j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour vous c'est que vous avez toutes et
tous une très bonne mémoire une mémoire
incroyable
capacité de stockage 2,5 pétaoctets ça
veut dire que votre mémoire peut stocker
si c'était un disque dur 13 millions de
films en full hd
ça fonctionne bien quand même alors
pourquoi ça marche pas bien parce que
votre mémoire elle vous accompagne
depuis que vous êtes enfant vous êtes né
avec vous avez retenu le visage de vos
parents vous avez retenu la couleur de
vos jouets où ils étaient rangés vous
avez retenu votre vie le lycée et le
collège l'université et vous retenez
tout avec donc vous ne remettez pas la
mémoire en question et c'est bien le
problème tout ce qu'il nous accompagne
tout au long de notre vie on le remet
pas en question jusqu'à temps qu'il ya
un mec qui arrive sur scène et qui vous
disent des trucs et aux fêtards ouais
d'accord
c'est un peu comme le jour où tu étais
en train de manger une banane il ya un
pote qui est passé qu'a dit attends la
banane elle c'est plus comme ça et là tu
as fait ah ouais là il y en a plein qui
se disent mais sait plus comment du coup
je ferai un tedx un jour dessus mais pas
aujourd'hui ok il faut remettre les
choses en question il faut savoir
comment fonctionnent les choses pour
bien savoir s'en servir en fait au final
je vous parlais par exemple de la
connaissance rétrospective les
connexions qui relie vos neurones ils
marchent pas forcément dans les deux
sens aussi bien l'un que l'autre il leur
faut une connexion dans un sens et une
connexion dans un autre sens on fait un
exercice concret je vais vous demander
s'il vous plaît à toutes et à tous de
penser à trois villes australiennes
maintenant ça doit être fini si vous
savez vous savez lever la main ceux qui
avaient spontanément trois villes
australiennes en tête pas grand'
imaginez maintenant si j'étais arrivé
pour commencer ce talk en vous disant
mon soir est-ce que vous avez que
canberra sydney et melbourne sont des
villes d'australie lever la main ce qui
sincèrement murray faible oui je savais
voilà presque tout le monde est un peu
de mito qui les flamands seriez tous
levé la main et vous seriez dis
sincèrement je sais ça donc je n'y prête
pas attention le problème de la
connaissance rétrospective c'est qu'on a
des données qui se baladent dans notre
cerveau mais elles sont pas bien
connecté 2 fait qu on réentend ces
données on croit les connaître alors que
dans le fond on les connaît pas très
bien parce qu'on n'a pas prêté
d'attention il ya 3 amis pour la mémoire
majeurs qui sont la tension
l'émotion et la compréhension et un
quatrième amie dont parle un petit peu
moins c'est l'imagination l'imagination
c'était le meilleur ami des tribus une
certaine époque des anciennes sans vie
de civilisation de toutes les
civilisations qui ont voulu transmettre
de la connaissance en réalité la
connaissance de la technique la
connaissance du savoir du village de la
famille de la connaissance médicinales y
avait pas de papiers à l'époque on a
cherché il n'avait pas de bloc notes
donc ils transmettaient tous à l'oral il
fallait faire en sorte que les autres
leur tiennent dans le temps on va le
travail et votre imaginaire vous avez
vous allez jouer le jeu mentalement
faites-le vraiment y'a pas de danger ne
renie rien juste imaginer des choses que
je vais vous demander d'imaginer
imaginer qu'il ya un bus comme ça devant
moi sur scène on va dire que c'est un
car il est là sur scène devant moi
il se promène dans le car il n'y a pas
de siège à la place il ya une main
géante à l'intérieur du car donc là ça
fait un peut chauffer les neurones c'est
normal c'est pas des images habituelles
mais forcé le dans votre imaginaire la
grance la grande main au milieu du quart
dans sept grandes mains il ya un oeuf
géant
il est tellement grand qui perce le haut
du car est tout en haut il ya deux s'ils
décident bûcheron qui essaient de
l'ouvrir
et il y en a la moitié de la salle qui
essaient de partir mais restez y a que
quatre images un quart avec une main à 9
et 2 si vous avez les images oubliez ça
n'a pas d'intérêt
imaginez plutôt maintenant que j'ai une
tâche dans mon cou bon coup et à
sherbrooke on pourrait dire que c'est un
coup tu as schéma on va enlever le et on
va dire que c'est un coup tâche à 3
mesdames et messieurs vous allez tout et
tous d'irkut h 1 2 3
c'est flippant mais c'est ça et enfin
pour terminer oublier ça imaginez que
maintenant je jette des oeufs vraiment
sur le e de ted je jette des oeufs il
dégouline c'est un petit peu dégueulasse
et juste après assis à côté du x il ya
un an un jardin géant qui a été posée là
vous voyez ce nom de jardin il vous fait
un petit coucou là à ma place il ya un
chanteur il ya johnny stark et l'a
donc à ma place vous imaginez joey starr
et puis ici jeu renversé une bouteille
du vin du vin de la ville de troyes
c'est un très bon vin donc là bas je gtd
hull il y avait un nain de jardin
gérante joey starr et du vin de la ville
de troyes vous avez des images ou et ça
j'ai capter votre attention j'ai mis un
petit peu d'émotion en essayant de vous
faire rire un tout petit peu avec les
images mais vous n'avez pas encore la
compréhension on va y venir tout à
l'heure on a deux types de mémoire on va
dire deux grandes familles la mémoire à
court terme et la mémoire à long terme
dans la mémoire à court terme on va
trouver principalement la mémoire de
travail la mémoire de travail c'est une
mémoire immédiate c'est un peu la
mémoire vive de votre cerveau durée de
vie 15 secondes nombre d'informations
retenu en moyenne
7,5 pour les plus fatigués d'entre vous
9 pour les plus performants d'entre vous
neuf informations qu'on peut retenir
temporairement vous comprenez maintenant
pourquoi dans burger quiz y pose des
questions pour gagner tous les goûts
c'est comme ça que l'émission réussi à
ne pas de d'être aux deux jeeps renegade
à la fin
la mémoire de travail c'est celle que
vous utilisez la majorité du temps alors
que vous devriez vous concentrer sur les
mémoires à long terme là y en a plein je
vous en citer quelques unes ya la
mémoire procédurale par exemple mémoire
procédurale c'est la mémoire du geste si
tu demandes un guitariste un morceau qui
connaît un tu l'as déjà entendu jouer à
étudier comment tu le joues tu peux
m'expliquer il sait plus te l'expliquer
par contre si tu lui donnes une guitare
s'il retrouve la première note les
doigts vont faire le reste c'est la même
mémoire qui fait que quand vous marchez
vous vous dites pas jambe droite après
ces jo tu sais le faire
en temps normal jeudi c'est le faire
après il ya la mémoire sémantique la
mémoire des données si je vous dis 15
c'était quoi déjà
voilà connaissance rétrospective tu
crois tu sais un truc mais tu le savais
pas tu as juste su que 15 115 c'était
marignan mais tu l'as pas connecté à
françois 1er est pas forcément à toute
l'histoire et la mémoire qui nous
intéresse le plus c'est la mémoire
épisodique la mémoire de souvenirs c'est
celle qui fait que tu te souviens de ce
que tu as fait hier suivant la soirée en
temps normal tu te souviens de ce que tu
as fait la veille la mémoire du souvenir
on peut la trafic et on peut utiliser
l'imaginaire pour faire croire au
cerveau que c'était un souvenir et ainsi
va le stockées dans la mémoire
épisodique donc meilleure mémoire
puisque mémoire à long terme et là on
peut rentrer beaucoup plus de choses et
beaucoup plus facilement et en faire un
rappel quasiment instantané par exemple
quand je vous ai fait imaginer des
choses tout à l'heure le cas avec la
main l'oeuf les deux si le coup tâche
les oeufs le nain de jardin joey starr
la bouteille de vin de ville de troyes
j'ai utilisé la mémoire épisodique pour
vous faire entrer un truc dans le crâne
qui vous servira à rien les décimales de
pi
là j'ai téléchargé dans votre esprit les
17 premières décimales de pi là il y en
a qui font non merci tu enlèves style
tout mais si c'est comme ça je peux vous
le démontrer j'ai utilisé trois images
différentes 3 c'est le début de pis
c'est pas un hasard pisser 3.459 de 6 5
3 5 8 9 7 9 3 2 3 6 4 6 2 6 4 3 0 de
cette infection
le confinement était pas
y avait quoi qu'il arrive sur scène
devant moi un quart incarcés 1,4 si tu
fais la comparaison un quart 1,4 dans le
car il y avait quoi une main exactement
une main il ya cinq doigts s'il ya qu
une main avec cinq doigts il ya 1,5 3,1
4,5 dans la main il y avait à neuf donc
neuf et en os de l'oeuf y avait 2 6 donc
2 6 2 6 2 6 ça fonctionne je vois des
yeux qui font rôle j'ai ça dans la tête
maintenant mais y'a pire ça c'est une
technique qui s'appelle la table de
rappel j'ai pas voulu détailler vous la
retrouverez facilement sur internet j'ai
utilisé aussi de la mnémotechnique ici
avec quoi qu'est ce qu'on a dit
d'ailleurs tous ensemble coûteuse la
même secte est revenu c'est ça coûte h
c'est un code secret mnémotechnique si
on enlève les voyelles il reste les
consonnes ctc hcc la première lettre de
5 le thé la première lettre de 3 le sait
la promenade de 5 h la première lettre
de 8 là-bas jeter des oeufs donc neuf
ici avec moi un des jardins c'est un des
sept nains donc cette lie avec qui au
milieu joey starr 9,3 j'ai pas trouvé
mieux
et là je renversé du vin de la ville de
troyes donc 23 mesdames et messieurs
sans vouloir vous avez retenu vous même
les 17 premières décimales de pi le pire
dans tout ça c'est que vous les aviez
peut-être pas tout mais le fait qu'on
sort repasser dessus on vient de faire
une meilleure rétention donc maintenant
vous connaissez beaucoup de décimales de
pi ya quinze jours il ya un bus qui va
passer dans la rue vous allez faire en
1/4 1 5 9 2 6 oui vous allez me détester
ce jour là quoi qu'il en soit vous avez
retenu quelque chose de plus compliqué
que deux numéros de téléphone même si
vous n'avez pas tout retenu vous avez
retenu comme quelque chose de plus
compliqué qu'un seul numéro de téléphone
si notre ami stéphane thomas avec ses
beats cohen il avait travaillé cette
technique il connaîtrait aujourd'hui son
mot de passe à 3 millions de dollars
l'an 3 millions d'euros c'est pire en
plus vous voyez la force et la
possibilité le cerveau il encode
l'information il a stoke et ensuite il a
rappelle c'est les trois étapes de la
mémoire stockage envoie encodage
stockage et rappelle notre problème à
nous tous ses combats khl l'encodage
depuis toujours on va le plus vite
possible on n'a pas de technique on n'a
pas de méthode on se dit ali ça va
rentrer et puis on est habitué à ce que
ça se stockent mal donc à ce qu'on
oublie et au moment où on veut le
rappeler on se rend compte que c'est pas
stocker et du coup on leur et encode on
leur apprend mal toujours et on s'en
souvient toujours pas et on fait ça tout
au long de notre vie ça nous paraît
complètement normal qu'en sortant de nos
études on se souvient plus de ce qu'on a
fait au collège au lycée ça nous permet
normal quand on a le permis de conduire
de pas être capable de le repasser deux
mois après
apparemment tout est logique on passe
une interrogation un contrôle un partiel
deux mois après on se souvient pu
tellement d information ça nous paraît
logique parce qu'on nous a pas donné de
méthode pourtant c'est très important le
cerveau et associatifs et comparatifs
c'est à dire que pour créer pour décider
pour penser il a besoin d'avoir accès à
un maximum de données du passé et vous
vous êtes habitué à ne pas mettre
beaucoup de temps dans l'eau codage et
beaucoup de temps à réapprendre ce que
vous aviez déjà mais vous aviez oublié
si vous mettiez dix fois plus de tant
d'attentions d'émotion de compréhension
de méthodes telles que la table de
rappel la mnémotechnique ou le palais
mental et bien en étant dix fois plus de
temps à l'encodage vous gagnez quasiment
100 fois plus de temps dans la rétention
final c'est énorme c'est juste un
changement d'habitudes à opérer pour
accéder à ces 2,5 pétaoctets qui vous
attendent nietzsche il disait la mémoire
c'est
la reconnaissance du passé par le
présent et je trouve ça joli parce que
grâce au passé vous pouvez mieux penser
mieux créer et mieux décider je voulais
c'est là dessus et si jamais la
prochaine personne ne vous demande
comment je m'appelle c'était fabuleux en
liga merci beaucoup